[Musique]
au mois de mars alors que le monde
entier se doit très pour échapper à la
cobi 19 beaucoup d'espoir se sont fondés
sur un médicament courant la chloroquine
et son dérivé hydroxy chloroquine des
déclarations passionnées ont contribué à
mousser la popularité de ces produits a
indiqué n'être des milliers de patients
sont vus prescrire dans l'espoir de
prévenir ou de traiter la maladie
d'où est parti cet engouement en mars
deux études menées en chine concluait
que l'hydroxyde clarkin semblait bloquée
l'action du coronavirus dans des
cellules cultivées en laboratoire
dans le passé d'autres travaux étaient
arrivés à des conclusions similaires à
propos d'un autre coronavirus celui du
strass il n'en fallait pas plus pour
alimenter l'espoir d'un traitement
simple et abordable
juste la chloroquine c'est pas compliqué
c'est pas cher
pourtant quelques mois plus tard force
est de constater que ces espoirs était
prématurée et dizaine d'essais cliniques
ont été menés avec des résultats peu
probants
une majorité d'experts conclu
aujourd'hui que ces produits sont
inefficaces
comment expliquer cet échec des
chercheurs allemands ont fait valoir
qu'on s'était trompé de cible
dès le départ les travaux chinois ont
été effectués dans les cellules appelées
verrou très souvent utilisé en virologie
elles sont issues de cellules isolées en
1962 dans les reins d'un sage africain
non seulement ce ne sont pas des
cellules humaines
mais les cellules rénales ne sont pas
des cibles de choix en le virus de
lakovic 19
ils leur préfèrent les cellules des
poumons par exemple or les cellules de
rêve et de poumons comportent des
différences pour infecter les cellules
vero le virus utilise une molécule
appelée kateb sin elle la chloroquine
bloquent l'action de cette molécule et
empêchent l'entrée du virus dans les
cellules de raids sage mais les cellules
pulmonaires humaines ont pu cat et sin
dont les infecter le sera ce kof deux
comptent plutôt sur une autre molécule
la tnt rss deux absentes des cellules
vero orb la chloroquine n'a pas d'effet
sur cette deuxième porte d'entrée
des chercheurs ont démontré l'importance
de ces subtilités
ils ont créé des cellules vero doté de
tmp rss 2 alors la chloroquine est
devenu inefficace pour stopper
l'infection
ces éléments expliquerait pourquoi les
essais cliniques n'ont pas été
couronnées de succès en plus tu nous
rappeler de ne pas sauter trop vite aux
conclusions
[Musique]